I passionately believe that strategic
communication is critical to success in
business and in life
but we must also think about strategy
and how we communicate that many of us
focus on our day-to-day work on just the
tasks we need to complete in executing
them well taking time to reflect on
strategy in our organizations and our
own life can help us be successful
I'm Matt Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business welcome think fast
talk smart the podcast
I am very excited to speak with Jesper
Sorensen Jesper is a professor of
organizational behavior at the GSB along
with being the senior associate dean of
academic Affairs Jesper specializes in
dynamics of organizational and strategic
change he teaches strategic leadership
crafting and leading strategy and along
with fellow Professor Glenn Carroll
Jesper wrote making great strategy
arguing for organization advantage
welcome Jesper thanks for being here I'm
super excited for our conversation
thanks for having me Matt it's really an
honor to be on your podcast well thank
you let's go ahead and get started uh
you've been studying and teaching
strategy for over 25 years can you share
with us how you define strategy and
explain how it's different from planning
sure so you know I think
um you know the tagline here the GSB
change lives change organizations change
the world what I always like to tell
students is if you want to change the
world you have to build great
organizations because large-scale change
always happens through organizations and
if you're going to build a great
organization you have to have the
resources to sustain that organization
and strategy is really about explaining
how you secure that organization's
economic prosperity and if you're a
public company that means how do you
maximize profits perhaps but even if
you're a non-profit you have to have a
strategy that is somehow the logic by
which you get enough resources to be
able to to survive and do what it is you
want to do now that's different from
planning like I think planning is really
about the order of operations right it's
the sequence of things that you're going
to do uh once you know why it is that
you have a reason to do something and
what the outcome is going to be and so I
think strategy is that sense much more
complicated because in order to get the
resources that you need you have to
engage with other actors so you have to
engage with your customers and your
suppliers and so on and so forth and you
don't have control over them planning is
about the things that you can control
okay but strategy is really much more
complicated in that sense so it sounds
like planning is is much more tactical
once you have the strategy you then
invoke the plans to enact that strategy
exactly you shared that one of the Prime
directives for leaders is to focus on
building a strategy what are some of the
mistakes or misconceptions you found
over the years that leaders have about
strategy or its role in their
organization
so I think the the biggest misconception
that a lot of managers and organizations
have and and leaders is that strategy is
not their job
so I think in a lot of organizations we
have this image of strategy being
dictated at the top that the CEO is
going to articulate here's what the
strategy is and you know it's like a
football coach sending the play in from
the sideline and then we're all just
going to go and execute them right and
so you'll meet tons of managers who'll
say I don't do strategy
I'm just about execution
but of course strategy is really about
how you're going to best allocate your
time and your resources that's
ultimately what it's about and so if you
have any responsibility in organization
you're doing strategy and so you need to
be able to engage with the strategy and
I think one of the things that happens
is that we disempower ourselves if we
think about strategy as that the related
misconception is then that people think
of strategy as kind of like a set it
once a year or once every five years
kind of thing and then we're just going
to go execute on that plan but you know
if you think that strategy is set you
know no no battle plan survives contact
with the Enemy right and so like as soon
as you start to do things things start
to change and so it's not just about
drafting this beautiful architectural
blueprint and then handing off for
somebody to go build it because you got
to adapt to the changing landscape so
I'm hearing you say that strategy is
something that everybody owns within an
organization it's not just comes down
from on high and that it has to adapt
and change I have been part of several
organizations where when people say
we're going to strategically plan
everybody's eyes roll and they think oh
we're just going to put another document
on the shelf or it's just going to sit
on some website somewhere and what I'm
hearing you say is that it's it's living
and you have to evolve it and
everybody's involved in it which leads
me to the next question which is in your
book and teaching you and Glenn Carroll
make a very convincing claim that
organizations should craft strategy
arguments can you share what you mean by
a strategy argument uh what are they and
how can they help What Glenn and I are
trying to do in that book is basically
you know help people think about
strategy not as just a set of analytical
Frameworks which is what we teach many
times in Business Schools you think
about the classic way of teaching
strategy in a business school is Porter
five forces or or or differentiation
versus low costs and those are all
really important but when you're doing
strategy on a day-to-day basis you have
to understand like how is this working
so it's an explanation and that's how I
do think it's related to communication
it's an explanation for how you think
you're going to succeed and that's an
argument and an argument is simply a set
of assumptions that lead to a conclusion
right that force a conclusion and so
what a strategy argument is it's a
statement about what are the Investments
and the activities that we are going to
undertake that's going to lead us to be
able to create and capture economic
value and if we can do those things
right if we can understand the
connection between those Investments and
those activities and how we create
economic value and how we capture
economic value then we can start to have
sophisticated conversations about like
what is it that's working what is it
that's not working and it gives us a
model through which we can see the world
the thing I feel is so powerful about
this notion of strategy as an argument
is one it involves how you think about
it because when we craft arguments we
think about things like who are we
speaking to what's the context and it
implies that this is a conversation that
has to be had again it's not some
dictation that comes down from from
somebody so I find that really powerful
and it also implies in an argument that
there is debate and discussion and
change and evolution and I think that's
really really important and it fits very
nicely with what as you know I teach
strategic communication and while I talk
a lot about the importance of
communicating strategically I'm really
curious to have you share your thoughts
on how communication is important in
strategy
so I think there's two different parts
to that and one just to key off of of
what you just said like I do think and
then in the book Glenn and I we we
devote an entire chapter to basically
thinking about how can you argue
constructively as a group in an
organization oftentimes what we say when
we teach you know if we teach MBA
students or Executives we say you know
you should go and you should argue more
in your organizations and a lot of
people are then like well whoa no wait I
don't want to do that because what
they're hearing is fight like and we're
not saying you should go fight more
because so a fight is kind of like you
know you're throwing assertions at each
other and you're just waiting for
somebody to give in so it's like a
street fight but there are ways to
structure debates and arguments so that
they are constructive or and part of
that is about having the ability to
listen to somebody else and hear what it
is that they're trying to say and and
hear what their logic is I think most
people
um believe things for a reason like they
have a reason for believing it you might
disagree both with their conclusion and
with some of their reasons but you can't
engage constructively in a debate unless
you hear them on that Dimension and so
really it's about how do you structure
engagements with each other to create
that space
I think the other part of communicating
strategically that's really important is
is when we think about delegation so
what we know is that if you want to
build a great organization you're not
going to be able to do that yourself you
can't make all of the decisions much as
you might want to and so we all know
that we have to be able to delegate we
have to be able to empower people and we
have lots of books that tell us
delegation is wonderful and even the
word empowerment sounds so wonderful but
of course the truth is most leaders wake
up at three in the morning
petrified because they delegated a task
to somebody else and what do they
petrified what are they scared about
they're scared that they're subordinate
is going to make the wrong decision and
at three in the morning what is the
wrong decision it's not the decision I
would have made so there's this tension
like on the one hand you don't want to
make all the decisions and yet
you want to make all the decisions and
so
um or at least you want somebody who
might be closer to the information to
make a better decision because they have
more information but you want them to
think about it the way you think about
it
and then the question is how do you get
people to think about things the way you
think about things that's through
communication so that's about really
explaining why you think we win why you
think we are a successful organization
why you think these sets of actions are
the things that we need to do in order
to accomplish our goals and so that's
where I do think really clear
communication is going to be essential
to effective strategic leadership
the fact that you are invoking the power
of listening and being willing to engage
in Conflict but productive conflict so
we can get to a collaborative place with
our strategy is a very different way of
thinking about strategy in general and I
think that's really powerful for all of
us to think about and clearly being able
to articulate your strategy packaging it
and communicating it in a way that not
only motivates people but also helps
make better decisions is absolutely
critical right I mean there's this
element of strategy that we have a I
think most of our stereotype of what
strategy is is very top down yes and so
then you just you would think broad you
know communication just broadcasting but
of course we also know that lots of
great strategies are discovered and
they're discovered because the leaders
were able to listen to their Frontline
workers or their front line managers
tell them here's something that's even
better than what we're doing now and so
of course strategy is really both it is
both top down and bottom up and so you
have to be able to to both be able to
articulate what it is that you want to
say and where you think we should be
going but then also be able to listen
and hear where you might be wrong
because I think the other part that we
really emphasize is in an argument well
how do you make an argument you make
assumptions yeah and assumptions are
testable like they're going to be proven
wrong or they're going to be proven
right and like you have to be open to
the possibility that the Assumption you
made yesterday has turned out to be
wrong today and that you therefore need
to revise your theory that doesn't mean
you have to go back and give up but it
means that you have to update your your
understanding of the world we've talked
a lot about testing assumptions and how
to really challenge yourself to be open
to what the the reality is instead of
staying fixed on what you thought it was
and thank you for re-emphasizing that I
have to tell you when I was doing
research for our conversation I had a
big smile on my face when when I saw
that in your class and in your thinking
about strategic communication and
communicating about strategy you talk a
lot about how important storytelling is
and I'm curious if you can help us
understand what makes a good story about
strategy
so if you think about strategy as an
argument then uh I think a natural
Criterion suggests itself
and that Criterion is logic so a good
strategy story on the one hand has a
clear narrative to it and you can follow
the steps and so on and so forth but it
should also be internally coherent and
that is the realm of of logic like in
philosophers and logicians have spent
centuries thinking about how do we
assess
arguments in terms of whether or not
like whatever assumptions you're making
do the assumptions that you do make lead
to the conclusion that you think it does
and that is I think incredibly important
in assessing strategy stories and where
it's particularly important is when
you're doing strategy for the future
like when you're trying to say here's
where we want to be in five years here's
my narrative well but think about it
you're telling a story about something
that hasn't happened yet and so how do
you know whether that's a good story
like you can say Well it resonates with
me it inspires me and those are
important and useful criteria but of
course they could also be foolishness so
you want to also be able to say okay I
don't know whether all these assumptions
are going to be true and I can't know
until I act
but at least I want to know whether if
they are true will they lead to the
outcome that I think they will lead to
and that's where we you know in the book
Glenn and I get into this a somewhat
technical set of chapters on thinking
about what is logical validity and and
soundness and so on and so forth which I
think a lot of people are like doing
strategy are like where did that come
from and I stopped thinking about that
in eighth grade or something like that
but I do think that that holding on to
those ideas is like where the way we
should assess each other's arguments in
the first instance is by the extent to
which they're internally coherent
right and and one of the things I I
strongly advocated whenever you're
creating content stories Etc that there
is a logical coherence things follow and
that their premises that you could
support I'm curious to get another
dimension of story that I I wonder your
thoughts on which is once you have a
strategy you have to propagate it in an
organization and and
sometimes I think the most effective way
to do that is not putting it on posters
or little note cards people have it's
the stories that leaders tell do you
have experience on that or thoughts on
how once we have the strategy how do we
actually communicate it and use story to
actually motivate people to align to
that strategy I I think first of all I
totally agree with the premise of your
question like I do think that
communication of these stories is really
important and I would add like uh
Relentless communication I think one
aspect of that is like it's very easy
to approach management and leadership as
a exercise in giving orders
and I think that's fine like I think
there is an element to it that's about
again delegation and giving orders but
but but maybe give people a little bit
of Grace in the sense of saying here's
why like here's what I'm thinking and
just let people into your mind and your
logic because then they're going to do a
better job but I just think that's the
most important thing and so I think the
more you can just be aware of the need
to always be communicating what your
reasoning is and what your logic is the
better off you'll be I absolutely agree
and I and if people can internalize your
logic they can then be able to not only
know what they need to do and feel
confident that it's the right thing they
can then communicate it to others so it
becomes a way of propagating that
information and they can more
productively disagree with you that's
true oh but wait a second you thought
that this was going to be true and it's
not so now boss we got to do something
differently it's not disrespectful or
anything like that just like the world
wasn't the way you thought it was and I
can help you do a better job right and
it allows for that immediate feedback so
you can make those adjustments for sure
before we end I'd like to ask you the
same three questions I ask everyone you
okay with that yep all right here we go
if you were to capture the best
communication advice you've ever
received as a five to seven word
presentation slide title what would that
be
the five to seven words would be a
classroom is a theater
oh so I had the pleasure of of working a
number of times actually with a teaching
coach named Barbara Lane Brown and she
was a former actor and uh theater
director and and she really helped me
think about how you know when you're
teaching a class which is obviously a
very strong form of communication like
you're putting on a play and you have to
think about all the different like think
about it the same way so like you know
when you're first starting out for
example you kind of tend to just kind of
like
okay let me just start talking like as
opposed to taking command of the room
like a play doesn't start by somebody
just wandering out on stage and deciding
to start well a good play doesn't a good
play doesn't and a good theater
performance has characters and their
different characters and so thinking
about yourself as an individual and like
the different characters that you might
deploy in the same class and thinking
about engagement with the audience and
how you move and all those other kinds
of things it was really powerful for me
it changed the way I taught and
definitely for the better
I have to say that I'm pleasantly
surprised and and a bit shocked I I see
you as somebody who is I mean you're a
fantastic teacher and you're very
logical and methodical and I love that I
now see behind the curtain literally and
figuratively that you you think about it
as a play and I think all of us should
think about the theater of our
communication now I don't mean we have
to be actors but think about the way the
environment's set up how are you
starting as you mentioned how do you end
how do you build excitement and all of
those are things that we can learn from
acting and and thank you that that
that's fantastic
who is a communicator that you admire
and why
so having listened to your podcast I of
course knew you're going to ask this
question you can I'm in general terrible
at asking at answering questions like
who's your favorite ex I'm sorry so I
was stopped no no that's fine so I I
texted my kids my kids are all grown and
I said you know how how should I answer
this question and one of my sons said
Bill Belichick
because I'm a big New England Patriots
fan and my other son said the Swedish
Chef because they picked him up it's and
then my daughter said Emmett who is our
dog one of our dogs
and I thought about because what Emmett
the dog does he has this amazing ability
to get me up with non-verbal
communication at 5 30 in the morning
like it's just stability so I actually
thought well what what unifies all those
because you know think about Bill
Belichick no most people would not think
of him as a right indicator because he
very intentionally actually I think is
not communicating doesn't want to say
anything and so so I actually thought
well while I was trying to make sense of
that and like why would they all say
that as a response to what they thought
I would be and I think it actually has
something to do with non-verbal
communication and and so then I thought
about some more and I actually think you
know I like one of the musicians that I
really have always enjoyed and loved is
a jazz pianist named Keith Jarrett who
has this amazing style of performance
and you know again entirely non-verbal
but if you think about the way great
musicians use pacing and Rhythm and kind
of the ability to create drama without
ever saying anything because I think
what I find hard about this question
it's a great question but I find hard
about it is it's so hard to separate the
message from the communication
style so that's where I think the the
music helps me think about okay like I
don't really know what the message is
but I know how it moves me in different
kinds of ways well first I am glad that
I had an opportunity to bring your
family together I was very curious how
you were going to have a football coach
a muppet and a pet lead to something but
you're right nonverbal communication is
critical and you are one of the very few
people to answer this question focused
on non-verbals most people speak about
people who communicate and speak in a
certain way
question number three what are the first
three ingredients that go into a
successful communication recipe
my first ingredient is not going to
surprise given what we have just been
talking about but I think the first
ingredient is clarify your logic so be
really clear about what your argument is
and that's saying that you know clear
thinking is what leads to clear writing
or clear speaking is is really key and
when I'm oftentimes giving feedback on
papers to students or or whatever like
it's usually about like the writing is a
mess until they get to the point where
they're actually clear about what
they're trying to say which is
oftentimes hard so that's not a
criticism but it's just like that right
that's the process and you know related
to that is writing is rewriting like you
have to keep doing it what you're doing
is you're revising your argument as you
go along
second ingredient uh I think is you know
imagine what the audience might hear
not just what you say like I think we
focus very much on like getting the
words right but not enough on what
people what the audience's perspective
is going to be and how they're going to
interpret the words and I think one of
the ways that I got better as a you know
a case class teacher was to be able to
anticipate better how students were
going to interpret a question like all
the different ways they could interpret
it and that I think is really key and
then I think the last ingredient I would
say is be all parts of yourself which
goes back to the this idea of the
classroom as a theater and like you
actually have within you many different
characters that you deploy at different
times the stern person and the joking
person and the and that you shouldn't be
afraid of using all all of them at the
appropriate moments in any given
communication task I really like that
notion of bringing your whole self and
giving yourself permission to be who you
are when you communicate that's very
powerful I feel a lot of us put on this
communication person instead of who we
are and that notion of really thinking
about the impact of your words on your
audience and planning for some of that
in advance I I think speaks very nicely
to your strategic thinking and clearly
logic is critical we've all heard people
who just ramble and we wonder why and
what makes sense well yes sir thank you
so much for joining us you made quite a
convincing strategic argument for the
value of strategy and further you helped
us understand what makes for good
strategy and good communication as well
thank you thank you for having me
thank you